you have to be passionate about this
business
90% of restaurants fail in the first
three years New York is number one this
is a culture of hustlers I'm surrounded
by some of the greatest chefs but some
of the greatest restaurant tours you
just meet some of the most incredible
people from all sorts of walks of life
Gabe is a competitor it seemed like he
opened up a new spot every year
Joseph Leonard Jeffrey's grocery fedora
Perla bar sardine and Moammar I don't
know that it was always gonna be this
big thing from the beginning it
literally was a group of people who sat
down at a table every night it was just
like how can we blow people's minds
tonight it was just like going to your
Palace apartment feels like a family
you
my for rare entry into the restaurant
world started in high school with a
little job at a Philly cheesesteak shop
but I really dug firmly deep into the
roots of the restaurant industry while
going to University of Wisconsin I
started by working in the back of the
house of a deli making sandwiches was a
line cook I saw waiters making more
money and working less hours so I went
to the owner and said I would like to
work less hours and make more money can
I be a waiter as a waiter in a college
town you see bartenders working the same
amount of hours making more money I
decided that I needed to become a
bartender he barked in at a great bar
cafe called cafe Moammar was a wine bar
but that was his first real bartending
gig and it was an amazing space when
Gabe got the job at Moammar he was given
terrible nights to be honest and Gav
came up with an idea to have a friend
who DJ's play records promote it don't
have a cover charge which on a college
campus is a big thing the guy was
presiding over a party that was
completely of his own generation it was
clear that he was connecting people and
thinking about the scene in a different
way from that moment there's a story
that when Gabe was a bartender he used
to keep like sticky notes behind the bar
and when he got each person's name he
would write it down in big letters and
stick it and so on his size of art in
front of their face so that he would
remember their name and then he wouldn't
a tourist they have a little notebook
that he kept we would run to the
bathroom and write down all the
pertinent permission he just learned
about this person so he then was able to
make connections keep connections get
regulars people came in because he had
this energy behind the bar and that was
what he loved to do growing up Gabe was
always really outgoing he had a lot of
friends he was the president in our high
school I think for a year or two
something like that and people kind of
always flocked to him I ended up
bartending my way through college during
that time span is wearing
I I found a lot of connections and love
for the industry I moved to New York and
I wanted to land myself a bartending
position at a great bar or great New
York restaurant I was swiftly rejected
in that pursuit and everywhere I went oh
come back when you have New York
experience meanwhile I'd be looking at
these clowns behind the bar who had the
job because they had New York experience
and I knew I could bartend circles
around these people I went to a
nightclub and the owner of the nightclub
said to me I don't have any bartending
positions now but I will in three months
I've got a bartender here who's leaving
you can be coat-check
and then this bartender will leave and
then you can have this job the only
problem with doing coat-check is it's
literally like humiliating profession
it's so embarrassing when your friends
come into the nightclub and give you
their coat I'm like here's your ticket
we went to college together I worked at
the cool bar in college and you couldn't
die to get into the bar now you work at
Goldman and I'm putting your coat on a
hanger and giving you a number I was
like so so bad and what ended up
happening was come January that
bartender left and I was like all right
this is my nod I'm gonna start
bartending in New York and his [ __ ]
owner didn't give me the job and he
hired some hot girl instead and I was
furious and so like in a fit
I just I'd quit like screw this ain't
doing the [ __ ]
and I left and somebody gave me a job as
a bartender I don't know if I saw as
young as when we were kids that he would
be working in restaurants but I think in
college I started to get that feeling
that this was kind of something he
really was passionate about and really
wanted to do I guess up until that
moment I always thought I wanted to open
a bar and then working at hearth is what
changed my opinion too
I don't want to open a bar where food is
secondary I want to open up a restaurant
where food is a primary focus that was
bartending three nights a week at hearth
I was bartending three nights we can try
back at plot J and I was working during
the day at Food & Wine magazine I met a
guy named Joey and he was the chef and I
was a bartender at pot J and then what
ended up happening was I scaled back on
my schedule at hearth and started
working more at pot J and then
eventually pot J went out of business
twenty-five-year-old version of myself
and an unknown chef decided to open up a
30 seat unknown restaurant and it's
called the little out at that time
Morimoto opened Budokan opened Del Posto
opened like these were the kind of
restaurants that opened with you know
names like Stephen Starr and Mario
Batali and Joe Bastianich like really
big people behind these big projects at
the time when you were reading about the
200 seat restaurant and how many tens of
millions did you spend on your build-out
to walk into a place that had 30 seats
where you could see literally the
features on every face that was in the
room and what they were showing was a
smile and you can see what's happening
in the kitchen and the food tasted
larger than the space did that felt like
hanging out at a friend's apartment and
eating amazing food is it was epic
reading it on paper in the New York
Times let me see that things were
definitely happening in the right
direction for Gabe he was definitely
going to like take things in some really
interesting new directions when he first
opened his first restaurant I think he
was kind of bitten by this bug of
hospitality and like I love what I do
and I love this thrill and I think from
there he just wanted to keep growing
people really took to it and it put both
of our names out there and that led
another restaurant and then we decided
that would be better if we weren't
business partners anymore I was 27 and
now a sudden I had all the free time
because I sold my restaurants and I had
money because I sold my restaurants and
so I took a year and I decided to you
know do a lot of self-reflection about
everything that I loved about the
restaurants that I created and every way
that I thought I wanted them to be
different I started to put together what
I thought was my ideal version of a
perfect neighborhood restaurant my
mother's father is Joseph and my
father's father is Leonard and so I took
my two grandfather's names and put them
together for the name of our first
restaurant the Northstar that sort of
drove us was this idea of creating the
restaurant that we wanted to have in our
neighborhood if we live there place that
we would want to go to have fun to feel
sort of like a cheers sort of
environment where you go in and like the
bartender's knew you you knew the
bartender's Gabe found a space on a way
to I think a birthday party that had a
for rent sign in the middle of the West
Village and then ended up becoming
Joseph honored Joseph Leonard is the
anchor it is the place I think about
when I think of Gabe's restaurants where
is the little owl felt like hosting an
amazing dinner every night
Joseph Leonard felt like hosting a party
every night
we're getting all of this traction and
getting all this like the perfect
momentum to be this neighborhood
establishment and then it got our legs
clipped out from under us I wake up one
morning to sirens at around 7:00 a.m.
and crashing glass and I popped open my
french windows to the apartment above
stick my head out and was just crawling
with fire trucks and they're breaking
the windows to the restaurant when I
went outside a buddy of mine in the
building said hey I think your friend's
restaurant is on fire yeah that was a
shock that was that was wild it was
crazy to see a place that we had spent
so many hours and with a hole in the
floor and you know the windows busted in
I saw Gabe you know out front just you
know taking taking it in talking to
somebody I was just watching furniture
just like they literally get thrown out
the window and I'm just watching stuff
just get hosed the fire also happened to
be about ten days after we had opened
our second restaurant so while we had
these challenges on one hand of opening
and building and working with Jeffrey's
grocery we're also trying to rebuild
it's you know Big Brother right across
the street dozens of restaurants were
offering to support every neighbor was
bringing like cards and cupcakes and
everybody that worked with us saying I'm
here let's let's put it back together
and when you're surrounded by that much
love from your community I realized we
had achieved the pen ultimate goal which
was we established ourselves to be a
fabric of the community that was a
feeling of we've got to come back
I knew that the most important thing
that had to happen for reopening Joseph
Leonard was keeping the team together
all of the neighbors who loved us they
didn't love just me they loved all of
the bartenders and all of the waiters
and all the cooks I went to two of our
investors and I asked them they could
front me money and they fronted me
$75,000
I emptied my entire bank account - which
was you know more than that
and I sat down with the whole team I
told everybody I said look I'm gonna pay
you 75% of what you used to earn every
week for you to sit at home if you'll
just wait for me and I might call you
and I might need you to sweep I might
need you to wash some windows and then
we're gonna reopen and I want you to be
around the meaningfulness behind still
paying the employees while we were
closed even when they didn't have a lot
of money in the first place to pay the
employees and it got pretty thin up to
the end
Gabriel was very transparent about that
and I think rightfully so he just wanted
to retain the fabric of the foundation
it's solidified a group of people that
really already did feel like a family to
be even more connected I'm so happy and
so proud that when we reopened we didn't
lose a single person you just see the
staff that were so happy to be back
there and gay was just so proud to you
know have that behind him at that moment
when guests started coming in and all
those familiar faces and all the people
that we'd served welcomed us back into
their lives again but sort of that
moment that it's like we're here this is
gonna be here for a while
around the corner is a restaurant called
Fedora and it's been called Fedora since
1952 Fedora is a special place in that
it constantly is referred to as a New
York institution there's a lot of
history that goes behind it it was the
first time since 1917 to 2010 where this
restaurant was getting ready to be
passed to somebody not in the family I
walked into the place and made sweets a
few places got the kind of soul that
fedoras got lean and you feel the soul
on the floor you feel it in the brick
feeling the ceiling like shits been
happening here since 1917 great things
and it had been called fedora since 1952
we felt like we should absolutely keep
the name it fits in all of the ethos
fedora led to where we're sitting Perla
and I had the same feeling that I had
when I walked into fedora I mean there's
bones here we're in Manhattan do you
have these quaint streets like Minetta
Lane we wanted to do Italian and Pirlo's
my grandmother's name
Perla was married to Joseph oh I love
Perla she was a big part of my life
raised me and we always called her Perla
she never want to be called grandma
because she thought it sounded really
old so just call me Perla Perla for me
was my big opportunity before Pearl I
had been the general manager of Joseph
Leonard and I'd been the general manager
of Jeffrey's grocery when we opened
Perla I was the general manager of
purlins I was also a partner and it also
gave Gabriel and I a chance to really
sit down and talk out all of the things
that we have been doing at the other
restaurants and really refine them and
bring them into a new generation of here
is the philosophy here's how we want to
communicate it and it coincided with you
know with our biggest opening with the
restaurant that garnered the most
attention it was a beautiful thing but
the concept of Perla has always been eat
pasta and listen to hip-hop
our show number five is where we broke
the trend of naming restaurants after
family members we started with a really
inauthentic like Hunter s Thompson gonzo
style of an izakaya you know it's like
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas style of
Japanese food it enjoyed wild success
for a year but ultimately I think the
biggest challenge with Chez sardine was
it was extremely niche I think the key
is to make restaurants that have more of
a timeless element and that's been the
pivot that we did and so we evolved Chez
sardine into bar sardine our sardine
keeps growing anchored by one of the
best burgers in the city it's become a
great gastropub the mole marked like the
Parisian neighborhood is our French
bistro we were on the right track with
that place in that garden was really a
defining thing for that restaurant was
like wow this is an opportunity to bring
our hospitality to a gorgeous outdoor
space my first bartending job in Madison
Wisconsin was at a bar called cafe
momart so it's an homage to my first
bartending job and the place that made
me want to do this for a living
a lot of the success in the growth of
this company has been because we've
found a bunch of great people to work
with and build opportunity to work with
them in new capacities people call this
little whisk Oh for so long and it
really started when it was just Joseph
Leonard and there was literally 13
people who knew each other from Madison
all working together and if you look at
that group now you know a significant
portion of them or at least the portion
that are still part of the company are
all playing leadership roles we've been
really good always since we've opened
about promoting from within you know we
have sous chefs that are now Executive
Chefs servers that are now general
managers bartenders that are now
managing partners I never thought I'd
get into management basically I thought
I was just hanging out for a little bit
like having a good time making some
money in the summer making some friends
and being in New York City I'm like that
was an exciting thing
Connie to know Gabe and understand that
he's he comes from behind the bar you
know like he's been in our position so
he's so easy to talk to and understands
what we're coming from easy to contact
so my first impression was just how kind
of humble and like any of us this guy
was and he was the owner it was hard for
me to leave a career I'm here it was a
big risk you know I went took myself and
put myself in the design school and I'm
just I haven't literally worked from the
bottom Gabe gave me my first design job
one of the regulars at the restaurant
you know I think Gabe had mentioned I
was doing his office hired me to do his
apartment and it was just kind of like
if I hadn't gotten those two jobs and
then kind of done another one for a
friend I wouldn't have a portfolio that
wouldn't have gotten me the job I have
now which is I'm working for an
incredible designer who you know works
for a magazine and running his company
while he does that full-time and so I'm
grateful you know
the one piece of advice that I think is
probably the least adhered to advice to
people who have dreams of opening a
restaurant is go work 10 12 15 years in
the industry before you get any ideas
about opening a restaurant for yourself
you have to be passionate about this
business about this life it's not easy
you know I I hardly ever see my
girlfriend I am still compelled to do it
make decisions I right or wrong make
decisions don't be afraid to fail
failure is fine if you don't lose
everything anything stay involved in the
community go check out other places be
inspired Travel bring those ideas home
and make your community greater all your
dreams drink a lot of coffee be willing
to work really really really hard for
what it is that you want you'll get
there
hopefully the future for happy cooking
hospitality is to continue to make
people happy and show them a good time
for many years to come it's about
looking at the people that have made a
successful whether its staff or regulars
first-time diners and making regulars
out of them it's continuing to push
ourselves to find ways to make the
restaurants in our eyes better if
there's a thing I'm most proud of it's
that there is a community around the
restaurants what I see for the future is
just continuing to expand that feeling
for people I think that would be an
amazing thing I hope that happy cooking
hospitality provides the opportunity for
all of us to come up with an idea a
dream and say I want to do this and as
long as we have the opportunity to help
people be creative get their ideas out
there and chase a dream and if we can
facilitate that that's what we want just
one word yeah
Joseph Leonard
[ __ ] Joseph Leonard handsome drunk
Jeffrey's grocery boy stirs oysters
oysters clams bar sardine Rose a farce
Rd unique no more slick pulla sexy
battle fedora speaking home long [ __ ]
hour